- How can someone who's
not sure how to address,
because here's the thing
too. I was get worried.
Cause even on the Voice,
like we've had these conversations
with the producers cause
we're turned around
and sometimes we. Yeah.
And so we don't know them.
We're not allowed to know them.
- Oh.
- So, so it could be a they,
a she, a he, we don't know
And so we turn around and
we, our big thing is like,
God, we don't want to offend anyone.
Like, you know.
- Yeah.
- So I think that's the thing.
I, I hate the cancel culture
and like, oh, they're canceled.
Cause they said that it's like, no,
it'll give them a minute to learn.
- Yes.
- Like give them that's the truth. Right?
Like, because it's new for everyone.
- Yes.
So people feel more comfortable
as they/them I'm totally for
that. I just think you have to
allow a little grace, right?
- Yes. You have to have mercy for people
that are trying to learn
this new thing and for me.
- [Kelly] Those trying.
I still mess up sometimes
because I was born a female and
was female my whole life
until I started identifying as
non-binary just a few months ago.
- Yeah.
So for me, I even have
times where I slip up,
like someone will be like, yes, girl.
And I'm like, yes.
(laughter)
But like, I don't really, like, it's.
- Not really, you're like, so I.
- You're like so.
- Don't really take it
personally when someone's like,
yes girl.
But I just, I don't know.
I think it's important that
people remember that this is a
new thing and it's absolutely
okay to make an accident as
long as your intention is right.
And that's by like, as
long as it's kind of like,
I had an experience with a
friend who had said, you know,
it's kind of like if someone
were to get your name wrong,
like if someone were to call you Carrie.
Carrie Clarkson.
- Well Carrie Underwood.
- They've done it a lot, actually.
- Oh no!
- Yeah.
I just was like, what sounds like Kelly.
- I'm like, we look nothing alike at all,
or sound alike, but I love her so great.
- Yeah she's great. But it would be like,
if someone continued to call you Carrie,
even after you correct them and say,
actually it's Kelly and
they say, okay, Carrie.
- Yeah.
- As long as you can
understand how weird it feels,
when someone messes it
up for another person,
then you can kind of understand
how the depth and the
importance of getting it right as,
and that's all it is about.
- That's a great way to explain it.
- Yeah. It's about accepting each other.
- Investing, trying.
- Yes.
- Yeah. Agreed. Agreed.